thanks for the ride oh wait a minute
peter we uh we need to talk
well we can talk later well we can talk
now
if you let me
what do we have to talk about why now
because we haven't talked at all for so
long your ant-man i don't even know who
you are anymore you shirk your chores
you you have all those weird experiments
and you're in your room you start fights
at school i don't know start that fight
i told you that
well you sure as hell finished what was
i supposed to do run away no no you're
not supposed to run away but
pete look you're changing i know i went
through exactly the same thing at your
age no not exactly
peter
these are the years when a man changes
into the man he's going to become the
rest of his life
just be careful who you change into
this guy flash thompson
he probably deserved what happened
but just because you can beat him up
doesn't give you the right to
remember
with great power
comes great responsibility
are you afraid that i'm gonna turn into
some kind of criminal
quit worrying about me okay something's
different i'll figure it out stop
lecturing me please i don't mean to
lecture and i don't mean to preach
and i know i'm not your father then stop
pretending to be
right
i'll pick you up here at 10.
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you